denn dort wird mit schumacher jetzt sein
debüt geben und das auch noch am
nürburgring nächste woche wird der sohn
von michael schumacher beim ersten
freien training an den start gehen
eventuell schon ein vorzeichen für die
kommende saison zu sehen ist darüber
möchte ich jetzt spreche mit norbert
haug mir nun live zugeschaltet guten tag
herr hauk habe es gerade gehört mitmacht
nächste woche sein großes debüt bei der
formel 1 was bedeutet das für ihn ist
das jetzt schon der aufstieg in die
beste rennserie der welt
na hoffentlich also ich hoffe ich dass
die formel 1 sich diese chance entgehen
lässt mich ist absolut fähig hat es
gezeigt jetzt in alle nachwuchsklassen
und die höchste zeit für den aufstieg
hat sich das erkämpft verdient viele
meinen vielleicht nur weil er den namen
trägt aber das ist falsch wer kann was
ist wirklich ein sehr sehr guter und
natürlich die historie der name der tut
der formel 1 und ich glaube die formel 1
braucht jede hilfe jede unterstützung
das mit jetzt gerade am nürburgring zum
ersten mal offiziell in einem alfa im
formel 1 training teilnehmen kann ist
natürlich großartig und wird bestimmt
die deutschen zuschauer ja es ist sehr
freuen wie mich und dass die premiere in
deutschland ist es ist eigentlich wie
aus dem bilderbuch
das stimmt wir hoffen dann natürlich
auch aufs nächste jahr sebastian vettel
hat ja jetzt bereits bei aston martin
unterschrieben was denken sie wie viele
deutsche fahrer werden wir in der saison
2000 21 in der formel 1 sehen wir einer
fehlt noch und es ist also den darf man
sich genauso wenig entgehen lassen
ich kenne etliche fahrer in der formel 1
die nicht die leistung bringen von nico
oder wer sehr sehr gut aufgehoben bei
einem der teams ich glaube es absolut
konkurrenzfähig wenn er
konkurrenzfähiges material hat ja
vielleicht sehen dass die teamchefs auch
so und wir haben gar drei deutsche in
der formel 1 ist natürlich wunderbar
werden als sieben von zehn jahren und
drei wäre eine ganz gute zahlen und
hoffentlich auch dass es jetzt gerade
sagen sie kennen einige fahrer die nicht
dieselbe leistung zeigen würden können
sie da welche benennen wie zum beispiel
platz machen könnten für deutsche fahrer
zu gefährlich
ich bin denn ich will ja nicht aus der
ferne beurteilen aber ich glaube der
geneigten zuschauer die formel 1
verfolgt
die fahrer sind in der regel alles sehr
gut und die wirklich ganz ganz wenigen
wie hamilton fest mit c3 sind sehr sehr
gut aber es gibt schon einige sich dann
auch oft beklagen oder wurde das auto
schuld hat und nicht der fahrer hat da
glaube ich schon dass da ein gestandener
kerl wieder nico und mega guten job
machen würde und vielleicht auch ein
bisschen zwischen windeln wo man
eindringen würde wäre schön wenn es
klappt man soll ja nicht zu viel wollen
aber ich glaube diese drei deutschen im
nächsten jahr
vettel mit schumacher nico hülkenberg
das wäre die richtige mixtur für die
frau bereits mehr nachrichten und
bikinis nur weil die schau dir hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren